avec nous guy cormier président et chef
de la direction chez desjardins monsieur
qu'hormis bonjour bonjour auxerrois
alors je vais commencer en vous posant
des questions sur les clients de
desjardins qui vous ont appelé qui vous
ont demandé des allégements d'abord ce
que beaucoup de gens combien de gens
vous ont appelé et demandent qu'on leur
donne de l'air un peu pour passer des
semaines difficiles
je dirais qu'en date d'aujourd'hui le 16
mars on est rendu à peu près à 200 mille
personnes à qui on a mis de l'avant des
mesures d'allègement pour les aider donc
c'est pas mal de monde est-ce que c'est
principalement les hypothèques ou les
cartes de crédit les prêts les marges de
crédit à écouter c'est un peu tout ça je
vous dirais qu'il doit y avoir à peu
près 50% que c'est essentiellement les
cartes de crédit les gens veulent une
mesure d'allègement veulent bénéficier
du taux qu'on a mis de l'avant on le
fait passer 19% à 10 points quelque part
c'est donc un vrai 50% que ce sont des
gens au niveau des cartes de crédit vous
avez un autre peut-être 25 entre sexe et
des reports de paiements hypothécaires
et parfois le reste ça va être des
marges de crédit personnelles devrait
évidemment là je mets de côté là là on
doit voir vrai quelques dizaines ou
peut-être vingt trente mille entreprises
aussi sur lesquels on a donné beaucoup
de soutien depuis les dernières semaines
s'ils seront bons jusqu'où on va
descendre d'après vous vos économistes
vos prévisions quand vous regardez les
prochains mois comment vous voyez les
prochaines semaines au québec
essentiellement où vous house ou vrai
bah écoute et social mais ce qu'on
constate c'est que les gère actuellement
son prêt de prendre la mesure de la
situation mais surtout sous l'angle de
bien comprendre c'est quoi les mesures
gouvernementales qui sont mises de
l'avant est ce qu'on peut en bénéficier
nous actuellement chez desjardins on
prend le temps d'être léger convoi qui
sont soit l'auteur de paiement aux puces
où on sait qu'ils m'envoient des
difficultés pour leur parler plus en
détail des différentes mesures
gouvernementales ou des mesures de
desjardins d'oxford et georges 5 légère
font le bon travail à ce niveau là pour
aller chercher le soutien qu'ils ont
besoin maintenant la reprise ou la
relance va vraiment dépendre la période
de confinement je pense
extrêmement difficile on le voit à
travers le monde des pays qui commence
actuellement à et ouvrait ou à
réinstaller une vie en société
très tranquillement alors que d'autres
sont continus de refermer ce alors c'est
difficile de vraiment avons des
prévisions mais clairement là que selon
selon nos économistes selon nous le 2ème
3ème trimestre 2 jusqu en septembre
coeur y est clair que ça va être une
période difficile économiquement
mais on voit déjà que tout ce qu'un gîte
le gouvernement les institutions
financières les gens sont au boulot
moi je pense qu'à la fin de la vie on va
voir la lumière au bout du tunnel noir
on le souhaite
jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à aller comme
institution pour ne pas que des petits
commerçants des petites entreprises des
entreprises plus grandes ne soit obligé
de faire banqueroute
à l'écouter on va aller très très loin
parce que le mouvement desjardins il est
aidé en sus u socioéconomique du québec
depuis 120 ans cette année et on vous
sert et comme on est présent la région
350 mille entreprises font affaire avec
desjardins labelle vous avez un paquet
de petites entreprises du salon de
coiffure aux dépendances alimentation
couche tard
ou alors vous avez vraiment la variété
d'entreprises qui fait affaire avec
desjardins
alors il est clair qu'on va aller de
l'avant que ce soit par rapport à mettre
en place à être la courroie de
transmission de tous les programmes
gouvernementaux fédéral et provincial
qui ont été vite les rangs des dernières
semaines ait cette courroie de
transmission là pour faciliter le
soutien mettre en place plusieurs
moratoires plusieurs éléments
d'accompagnement non directeur de
comptes sont déjà au téléphone pour
appeler nos entrepreneurs pour voir
certains vont bien en passer il ya des
entreprises qui vont vraiment bien parce
que travail dans autour du domaine de la
santé travaille déjà à accompagner
certaines mesures de relance mais
d'autres vont avoir besoin de notre
commun alors ça va être du soutien de
région on verse annuellement 80 à 90
millions en dons et commandites dans
toutes les régions du québec de
l'ontario
c'est clair qu'on va continuer de faire
ça les festivals des activités
culturelles des organismes
communautaires
on va vraiment aller dans tout ce que le
québec connaît de desjardins
là c'est le modèle pour notre logique
est bon
bien par ailleurs le gouvernement
fédéral et le gouvernement du québec ont
pris ont pris de vos épaules un peu de 2
du risque pour certains près la donne
des précieux qui ont le risque et non
pas vous est-ce que ça ça vous donne une
marge de manoeuvre pour être angles
entre guillemets plus généreux avec
votre nom bah tout à fait dans le sens
où actuellement au travail vraiment
partenaires et je pense que c'est comme
ça qu'on va sortir de la situation
économique dans laquelle on va on va à
aytré on est actuellement tout le monde
doit mettre l'épaule à la roue c'est pas
un acteur ce soit le gouvernement les
institutions financières les sociétés
d'état les organismes comme notre diapo
un acteur qui vont régler à lui seul la
sortie de la crise dans laquelle on est
actuellement c'est vraiment un travail
d'équipé joffard convoi relancer cette
économie d'eau qu'on va relancer notre
société et oui quand on voit le
gouvernement provincial et fédéral faire
preuve de grand nombre aux activités
comme ils l'ont fait depuis la mi mars
pour mettre en place des programmes mais
ça vient et d une institution financière
comme desjardins à pouvoir aller encore
plus rapidement le gouvernement a la
capacité financière au une une tolérance
pour le risque où ils peuvent aller plus
loin qu'une institution des mains comme
les jardins mais nous desjardins nous
avons accès à ces trois cent cinquante
mille entreprises lorsque le
gouvernement a pas nécessairement donc
le travail en commun fait qu'on est
capable d'aider déjà déjà là juste le
l'encours comme d'urgence du
gouvernement fédéral de près de 49 qui
vient en aide aux entreprises déjà chez
desjardins si tout près d'un demi
milliard de dollars en quatre jours
qu'on a déboursé auprès de plusieurs
entreprises alors on voit un meneur un
travail rapide si ce fait notre rôle à
nous c'est d'aller au devant des
entreprises et de les aider rennes
comment on n'est pas de 20 personnes
mais comment va se porter l'économie
dans six mois je cormier d'après vous
bah écoutez moi ce que je sais que ce
qui me rend optimiste c'est de voir la
rapidité des mesures qui ont été mises
de l'avant par plusieurs intervenants
dans l'économie avant cette situation là
vous aviez une économie qui se porte etc
eh oui à la fin d'un cycle mais une
économie qui se porte bien
on était en plein emploi il y avait des
innovations il y avait des projets il y
avait deux là
man de la part des consommateurs des
entreprises et y avait une offre alors
il est clair que le tout arrêter
brutalement mais la rapidité des mesures
gouvernementales
le soutien que l'on n'a jamais vus dans
une crise précédente comme comme celle
qu'on vit actuellement me rend optimiste
je crois que comme je le disais dc dc
septembre octobre ça va clairement avec
des mots plus difficile
on va voir plein indicateurs qui vont
qui vont devoir être toujours plus
négatif l'autre mais mais il est clair
que ces mesures très peu active de
l'ensemble des intervenants ne porte à
être positifs sur l'horizon à tout le
moins du début de l'année 2021 revoir
une relance économique mais on a nos
pauvres on n'aura pas des indicateurs
économiques comme nous avions à la fin
on aura pour cent au début 2010 21 on
parle de plusieurs années de revenir à
l'économie comme on aime en 2010 et pour
une entreprise qui connaissait des
problèmes avant cette crise là faut être
lucide aussi en a qui ne passeront pas
au travers et vous serez obligé marc
marquez qui vous aurez jamais oui toute
la logique vous oublie a à dire mais
c'est terminé on peut plus vous prêtez
il ça va arriver là comme ça aussi à
écouter ça va ça va vraiment la posture
que l'on actuellement chez desjardins le
mode à cette flexibilité souplesse bien
appétit alors on va mais tout l'avant
pour vraiment accompagner nos
entrepreneurs ces entrepreneurs la peine
avait il avait débordé du courage avant
la crise la crise est arrivée et ont pas
perdu leur courage n'ont pas perdu leur
capacité d'innover et ont perdu leur est
évidente c'est juste difficile en termes
de liquidité qui donc avait avant
vraiment le dire on met fin à notre
partenariat où on n'avait pas cette
entreprise là vous pouvez être sûr qu'un
mouvement desjardins comme il l'a
toujours fait on va vraiment tous
mettent en oeuvre avec les programmes
gouvernementaux maric nos propres
initiatives à nous pour faire preuve
d'ingéniosité parfois c'est dans le
montage financier
parfois ça permettait de celui que vous
avez trois cent cinquante mille
entreprises comme desjardins on peut
mettre en contact des entrepreneurs
aussi deux entreprises moins de
difficultés en même secteur peuvent
peut-être apprendre à travailler
ensemble puis on crée de nouvelles
entreprises
le plein d'idées comme ça que desjardins
pour faire à travers son leadership et
ses claques on va travailler dans ce
sens
intéressant entendre du cormier
président et chef de la direction chez
desjardins merci de nous avoir parlé en
direct aujourd'hui